and what he was doing was every day he
would wake up at like whatever five or
six in the morning and he would go to
phil's coffee and he would sit down with
his laptop first he'd tweet out that he
was at phil's every single day and then
he would start
just literally emailing and tweeting at
people that they should be posting their
product on product hunt or hey i posted
it for you would love to hear your
comment or hey i noticed this product
that's a lot like yours i wonder if you
know or like that's in your industry you
should check this out and all he was
doing was like manually being the human
notification system for product time he
was the he was the human invite system
the notification system the retention
system he was all of it
[Music]
i have a feeling you're coming with fire
or something you seem fiery today i got
some good stuff uh also i just watched
do you ever watch bar stools interviews
with people you watch are you talking
about the caleb presley one
i don't know who that is maybe that's
his name it's the one with their they
interviewed aaron rodgers i watched it
today dude
his name's caleb have you seen it so
it's called uh
it's called sunday
what's it called like conversations and
basically like ice cream yeah it's like
this like chubby guy named glenny balls
who's sitting in the background and then
it's caleb who's like a bro but he's
kind of he's actually really funny he's
hilarious he's quite smart and he
interviews these people he asked the
best questions he's so good have you
seen the past ones
i've seen a few of them this one is the
first one i've watched like the whole
thing and uh
god he's good man he that is amazing so
i watched that and sometimes that's all
it takes you just see someone being
great at their thing and you're like i'm
gonna be great today that's it i'm gonna
be great today
i saw great now i need now i need to be
great he makes me self-conscious caleb
presley is is is very very good at these
funny awesome interviews he's great on
the spot he's very good yeah he delivers
um all right so let's do can i tell you
something this is kind of amazing all
right this is gonna be a little hard to
share on here but i put this in to the
dock so you can click the links uh ben
if you can let's screen share some of
this stuff that's gonna i'm gonna tell
you
this is
i saw this ad on instagram and this is
the most amazing marketing funnel i've
ever seen
maybe ever but definitely for a musician
so check this out
stop scrolling you have 24 hours we're
carolunka an independent hip hop group
last year we had the honor of being
placed on brock hampton's official
community playlist and we were also
shattered out by kenny beats kira lanco
go off i bet you can do it this year
we're trying to grow our fan base so for
the first 15 people who dm us on
instagram in the next 24 hours we're
going to send you a special gift swipe
up the dms now so the the beginning of
the the audio didn't play there but he
goes do you recognize these people and
it's like biggie pock whoever like just
like a bunch of famous rappers it goes
stop scrolling and then he basically
does this little thing so i was like so
so uh ben levy ben sent this to me and i
was like what is this amazingness let me
i i must swipe up i must know what this
free gift is so i do it what does that
lead you to it opens up facebook
messenger
with a direct message already ready for
their like for their team and it just
says send it automatically sends them a
message from you saying send me the free
gift
okay so that happens and then they they
respond yo what's good immediately right
so you're like okay i don't know what's
happening here but i'm intrigued the
next thing that happens i have
screenshots of the stuff um
below you blow some of your research so
they go yo sean what's good so they use
my name in the in the
thing they pull it from facebook
messenger
and then
it says give us a little bit we'll get
back to you asap with your gift and some
more details thanks for your patience
okay cool
one day later i get a message it's an
audio note from the guys
who are the the rap group and it's
basically like introducing themselves
and and again this is kind of mass
produced but it works they go yo sean
and then it's the audio which is like yo
here's our story where these guys blah
blah here's what we're doing
and then they said
um you know for your gift we wrote your
own custom song we personalized the
lyrics just for you
and um
and so you know let me know what you
think it's links to us to links to their
soundcloud and it says sean king of the
first million that's the name of the
song
so then
[Music]
now he don't message us invest your
funds with the fiat get it done but i
can't afford it to keep it real so they
sent the song and i'm like okay well i
don't know what's happening right now
but like
this has never happened before where you
go from there's an instagram and an
instagram ad about a band that you never
heard of and you swipe up then they send
you an audio note and a personal message
then they send you a song the following
day that's like got your name in it and
then they followed up again and they're
like yo
i don't know if you're in new york i'm
gonna pretend you are we're doing a show
here's the here's a link to a show
here's the tickets
and then they send like this automated
graphic using canva of
you could see it there it's like me
crowd surfing uh it's like down i don't
know what is going on but this band is
kind of genius in the way that they're
promoting themselves and they're still
small they're called keralanka they're
still small
but
when i saw this i was like i don't know
they may not they may or may not be the
best musician but they are probably have
the highest overlap of
market like kind of marketing genius for
a young band
and they play music right it's like
there's a lot of marketing geniuses out
there but they don't make music there's
a lot of musicians but they don't know
anything about marketing these guys know
enough about both to be very dangerous i
just thought this is amazing is this
uh
effective you think i don't understand
so they're basically doing all this to
get you to buy tickets to their new york
show is that right
well it's not just that like it's not
just to buy takes a specific show it's
basically the way i think about it is
every business
you gotta find a way to get like your
first hundred or first thousand
customers who love you
and that's like a really specific thing
it's like i just need a thousand
customers who love us whether it was for
this podcast like we needed a thousand
people to listen who actually really
love the show
and um and every business has this and
so the question is like how do you
actually do that and uh at yc they have
this thing that they say do things that
don't scale they talked about the early
airbnb guys how they used to go
and they themselves would go and call
all the hosts of their new york airbnbs
they would go to their houses they would
take professional looking photos so that
the listings looked better and people
were always laughing like you know
that's not going to scale and they're
like well first of all it doesn't even
matter if it scales because right now i
don't need scale i don't have scale i
just need something that's going to get
a thousand people to really love us
and um that's what these guys are doing
i thought this is just an amazing
example of like
actually betting on that strategy which
is that you need a small group of people
to really love you and go to bat for you
not a bunch of people who just kind of
sort of like you or oh yeah i got you
know we got 10 000 views on this thing
it's like okay but those those views do
they matter what are those views worth
versus somebody who's got a story to
tell like i'm doing right now or
somebody who's really impressed by you
or feels interested in you or is
invested in your story actually goes and
clicks and learns more about you and you
know it goes deeper down your funnel so
i think that this is amazing because
they're showing they're brute forcing
that thousand thousand fans who who
really care about them dude i always
hated this thing of well it doesn't
scale or you got to build the scale i've
always hated that conversation for a few
reasons number one most people aren't
going to make it to the point where they
ever have to worry about that number two
you can brute force it and just manually
and by hand do things to a pretty large
number i think the largest number that
i've seen i let's see but i think mr
beast uh is is his aho operation is
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
that's a pretty brute force not i i
don't know what it looks like but just
talking to him fairly unsophisticated
operation i think when i talk to
nerdwall you know nerdwall it's a it was
a blog that was at the time making like
30 million in revenue and i i think like
15 million in profit incredibly i like
saw a little bit behind the scenes super
unsophisticated what what are some other
things and it was basically just them
just blogging what are some other
examples of things that you've seen that
are
look like a tech or internet based
company on the outside but behind the
scenes are like pretty rudimentary and
not even like they've not even
thought like oh we need to automate or
scale or whatever so our buddy ryan
hoover built product hunt and um he
listens to pod so he he came on the pod
as well and told the story but
i was there kind of like front row
when he was building that thing meaning
like i think i'm user number 17 in
product history or something like that
like very very early first dozen people
or so that were on the platform and so
and for some of us he was sending like
updates on like literally what he was
doing to build it
and what he was doing was every day he
would wake up at like whatever five or
six in the morning and he would go to
phil's coffee and he would sit down with
his laptop first he'd tweet out that he
was at phil's every single day and then
he would start
just literally emailing and tweeting at
people that they should be posting their
product on product hunt or hey i posted
it for you would love to hear your
comment or hey i noticed this product
that's a lot like yours i wonder if you
know or like that's in your industry you
should check this out and all he was
doing was like manually being the human
notification system for product time he
was the he was the human invite system
the notification system the retention
system he was all of it and
at the time i was like this guy's
literally
like sending out like hundreds of
personal welcome emails a day
maybe 100 personalized tweets per day
and then he would like you know sure
enough by six or seven p.m he'd close up
his laptop he'd go to the gym and he's a
very like structured guy and he would
like go home he he hits the bed early
he's not like uh you know he's not like
going out and socializing or doing
anything like that he'd wake up again
the next day and he would do the same
thing and sure enough that community
that we were part of i think that first
group he sent it to was like maybe 25
people
and it didn't even have his own website
he was using this thing called linky
dink at the time it's like some
third-party tool to go use
and every day he would send out the
email more email digest in the morning
of the cool stuff people posted and then
he would tag each person with
individualized thing oh sean i know you
guys had once looked at building a
product like this what do you think
about this and get you to share your
thoughts because he was asking in such a
nice personalized way that okay i'll go
ahead and reply but that generated all
of the activity for that early community
and why did product not work why did it
sell for 20 million dollars well because
at the beginning he got the right people
from silicon valley to actually
participate in the thing
and the way he did that was like it's
like when you watch somebody build a
fire it's like first they're just like
you know they're just hitting the flint
or they're rubbing the two sticks
together just to get the spark and then
when it's there they're sort of covering
it they're just blowing on it gently and
then they're adding just the next little
few pieces of sticks and they know it
could go out at any moment and that's
how it feels to build a community i saw
you do the same thing with trends
basically right like for trends when you
wanted to launch that
it was by no means going to be a slam
dunk
and i think most of us who are in trans
would say the research reports you guys
sent out which was the product
they were cool
but the real reason anybody liked trends
i think was the facebook group and all
it was was a facebook group there was
nothing you know you didn't build that
you just literally went down there and
typed typed you know a title in and hit
enter
and then but what made the facebook
group good was you picked you
hand-picked who could get in
and then every day i felt like you were
sharing like some super high quality
stuff to get a conversation started in
the group chat was that intentional when
you do that 100 it was intentional and
so when i i did two or three interesting
things so this yeah so trends right now
is making many many millions of dollars
in subscription revenue and it's pretty
simple and there's like i think there's
only five people who work on it so it's
like a pretty profitable thing and
we added these people to this facebook
group and i would do a few things the
first thing i would do is even people
who didn't pay who i thought were
impressive like you or some of our other
friends i'd be like hey i'm adding you
to this group and i would just tell them
and i would manually add them and i'd be
like oh look who just joined you know
it's shawn shawn has done all these
impressive things funny seeing you here
how cool um if you have any questions
for uh sean just like ask him right here
in the comments and i would do that all
the time so i would add these people who
did that that worked by the way because
i was like oh [__] this group has cool
people and it's in reality you added 300
paid members that i've never heard of
and then you added one interesting
person but you made that intro post
baller you're like
you ever seen a plane fly yeah that's
because of this guy you know it's like
it was always the most like ball or
intro you're like
um you know
did you know they didn't have hundred
dollar bills until this guy came around
it's like i did that all the time and
and the other thing i would do is i
would just write out all these long
posts of like interesting things that i
was thinking about and then i would tag
certain people who a either accomplished
something like that and would talk about
it or b i would write comments for smart
people and
message them and say hey
do me a favor post this on there or i
would write posts for other people and
make them comment one time uh when
hubspot was looking to buy us i saw that
brian halligan the then he's the founder
and then ceo of the company he joined
and i messaged like 80 people and i said
hey uh
reply to brian here's the message to say
to him
and so many people commented and that he
checked in like eight hours later he's
like oh my god i've been overwhelmed
with replies and notifications i can't
believe how thriving this community is
uh and i remember thinking like got him
got him and that's but that like
interaction is how you make all like
that's that feeling you want all
community members to feel we used to do
that all the time but yeah ryan hoover
is a good example of people who have
grown without like really caring about
scaring scaling we should have like a
segment another time where we like
actually think about like the most like
thrown together duct tape [__] that
we've seen that has gotten quite large
um and i'm gonna give you another
um
angle towards this so there's one which
is the brute force do things that don't
scale and they almost do them
even longer than that they do it even
past the point where you shouldn't be
able to keep this up like airbnb still
does that photographer thing by the way
they turned that unscalable thing of
them going to people's apartments taking
photos for them and saying hey we'll
we'll improve your listing for you and
now they just have a fleet of
photographers around the country that'll
just come do this for your listing it's
like it's that they turned it into a
scalable thing and that's another thing
when people talk about well that's not
scalable it's like uh yeah it is like
they'll talk about like an ad agency and
they're like that's not scalable it's
like what do you mean of course it's
scalable you just hire 5 000 employees
like that's scalable and maybe that's
not what you want to do but like yeah
everything virtually everything is
scalable
like you just have to add a ton of
people probably
most things can scale past what most
people think uh like you know this also
happens in engineering all the time you
work with engineers and they're like
well we're going to need to build it
right before we launch or we're going to
build it right because this won't work
in production and so this won't work
when it scales it's like then you hear
these stories like yeah facebook was
written in php why i don't know that's
just the language he knew at the time
and that's what he did you know it's
like and yeah actually it still runs you
know years later it was still running in
that like way past where it was supposed
to um and dude i've got friends that are
early at uber and friends that are still
at uber and a lot of people don't know
this but i they might consider him a
founder but the first or second employee
was this mexican guy and you know he i
think he was lived in america for a
little while but at the time he was
living in mexico and so the early
versions of uber were written with a ton
of spanish in the code and and so my
friends who were earlier they told me
yeah like i forget this guy's name do
you know who i'm talking about
i've i remember reading about him but i
don't know his name topic yeah he was he
was mexican and so they and he had you
know his friends in mexico were like
yeah well well i might i know a good
agency we're going to have him do it and
they said it was kind of thrown together
and kind of janky and i've got friends
now that still work there and they say
every once tomorrow we'll find spanish
in the early code base because that is
you know what these guys are writing
we'll find like spanish notes and things
like that and that was the early version
of uber
and think about how many rules of uber
got violated of how many rules of
startups that uber violated so for
example
um
the uber founders
travis and um garrett
they
didn't work on it full-time
uber was not a project they were willing
to do they just literally tweeted out
hey we need a general manager and
random guy named ryan graves was like
i'm a hustler i'll do it and they're
like all right cool
it's like they literally like delegated
the ceo job then did they have a super
strong technical team technical
co-founder who could write the code and
do this in-house nope use the
third-party dev shop to build the first
version of the app they outsourced the
coding you mostly the investors who
invested in uber would tell you if
you're a product guy and you go in and
you say yeah i'm gonna just use an
agency to write the code for the app
they'd be like uh yeah this is not yeah
no go
okay then what's the next thing then
they literally broke the actual laws it
was like running and they they got a
cease and desist from san francisco
saying hey for every day you're
operational you owe us five thousand
dollars per day and they just kept going
then the next you know they just
violated rule another one at the time i
remember at the time when uber first
came out airbnb was was popular at the
time
and i talked to our investor i was like
should we be doing a product like this
he's like oh no bits not atoms that was
like a common phrase in silicon valley
which is you want to do startups that
are software based because they can
they're the ones that can scale and have
profit margins
all these things with real world cars
and homes and t-shirts and stuff like
that like that stuff super hard to scale
ends up being super super low margin
and okay you know some people say oh
they're right you know uber's not that
profitable but the reality is that the
founders and investors in uber did
fantastically well um scaling this thing
up and it was kind of a narrative
violation there was all these narrative
violations all these
these general rules that were broken
that like today if you said yeah i'm the
i'm the founder of this thing no i'm not
working on it full-time i found a guy on
twitter to be the ceo and then we're
using this agency in mexico to build the
app yeah we're the next big thing that
doesn't fly and guess what it worked
dude we got to go on a quick story
tangent that's kind of what this whole
first half is going to be i guess but
there's this guy named scott belski i'm
friends with them or i used to be a
little uh friends with them i haven't
talked to him in a while but you do you
know scott
yeah i'm i like him a lot i like to
think of freshers though the reality is
i've talked to him twice yeah friendly
with him he invested in my company and
i've hung out with him once or twice he
doesn't know this but he's kind of like
i'm his secret admirer like he's like
this like good looking handsome dude who
dresses nice as nice and seems like
really wealthy and rich and like i i
like if i see him i'm like dude you are
the best and i've talked to him if you
have 10 million dollars at a jaw line
guess who's all in sam is all in yeah
yeah definitely all it so like i love
this guy and uh he's great so basically
i got to tell you a quick scott belsey
story so right now he's like uh an
executive at adobe but not just like an
executive i'm pretty sure he's like in
line to be ceo and a lot of people don't
realize this adobe is one of like the
30th largest companies in the world i
think their market cap is like three
four hundred billion dollars and scott
belski is he's pretty young he's in his
early 40s and he uh i cold emailed him
to invest in the hustle and that's how i
became friends with him and i met with
him one time and he goes yeah so like
when i was 26 years old i was starting
my company called behance so behance is
basically it's behance and dribble or
like the two companies where you go
online and designers can host their
portfolio and kind of talk to one
another and he was like i was just
starting this company and in my head i
knew he worked at goldman and i knew
that he was from like a wealthy like
jewish family i think his fa his
grandfather started like kaplan you know
kaplan university uh in that way
yeah and so i was like stereotyping him
oh you guys just you had everything
handed to you to him and like he told me
a few stories where i was like oh you
actually like it's not exactly how it
was from the outside and he said i left
goldman and i was making 90 grand a year
there and when i left i had like 50 or
60 thousand dollars saved i started
behance it didn't go very well and we
bootstrapped it and i noticed that with
behance we were getting a lot of traffic
from two different websites the first
was called stumbleupon and people and
designers would post school designs and
we would get traffic from stumbleupon
and the second was a small company
called pinterest and i emailed both
these guys uh and this was i forget what
year 2011 2010 he goes i've emailed
these guys i go hey you guys are sending
us like hundreds of people a day which
for us at the time was a lot of people
what what are these websites and this
guy ben told me about this website
called pinterest and then this guy named
garrett told me about stumbleupon and
ben was like hey i'm going to raise a
little bit of money do you want to
invest it's a 3 million evaluation and
scott was like dude i only have like 50
grand
and but i don't want to like look like a
noob to this guy whatever i'll invest
fifteen thousand dollars and that's a
big deal to me and then garrett was like
hey um my friend and i are starting this
other thing none of us are gonna work
there because i'm too busy running
summer pond but it's basically like a
car service and uh scott was like i
don't wanna invest in a limo company
like there's no way a limo company's
going to take off uh but like i don't
want to look like an idiot this guy's
been sending me some traffic and i kind
of want to like appear a little bit like
a big shot and so he gave him fifteen
thousand dollars i think at a 3.5
million valuation and he did both of
these in the span i think of about two
weeks so he's like i basically had like
50 or 60 grand in my checking account at
the time my startup that i was
bootstrapping was only doing okay it
wasn't making much profit and i was
doing consulting on the side to pay the
bills but i did my wife was like angry
at me but i gave him each fifteen
thousand dollars fast forward however
many years they both went public around
the same ish time and i remember sending
him something to his house and he sent
me his address and i remember the
address being this like really fancy
town home because i looked it up and i
was like
doing the math and i'm pretty sure each
of these fifteen thousand dollar checks
turned into around fifty to a hundred
million dollars each inside a span of
like you'll have to look up when they
went public but they almost went public
right around the same time and they gave
them money each at the same time and
another thing a lot of people don't know
is behance his company sold i think for
175 million dollars and i think he owned
he told me around 70 of it he owned the
majority of it and so this guy has just
knocked it out the park over and over
and over again and a lot of it came
because of uber and pinterest early on
and he was like i don't think these are
that good of ideas but i just i don't
want to look silly
that's a that's an amazing story i love
that story it reminds me i uh i just got
a dm
from this guy by the way this is nowhere
near
related i'm not trying to compare apples
to apples here it's very hard to have a
story that compares to uber and
pinterest but
uh there's a guy who i don't know maybe
six months ago or nine months ago
something like that i was like getting
kind of interested in the like ai stuff
about like you know this basically
artificial intelligence i can
create art and things like that and i
said something offhand on the pod so
somebody reached out and they were like
hey you know heard you're interested in
this i'm trying to make apps that will
do this
uh we just released our first one you
know i want to see what you think about
it and uh you know we're raising a
little bit of money we'd love to see if
you wanted to invest
never replied
i go uh i get another dm or no i uh
i see somebody mention this app and i go
i go click on the founder and i click
the dm oh this guy dm me a while back
saying i invest i should i should see
how it's going so i go hey how's the biz
going i'll share a screenshot of this
hey how's the biz going and he goes
good man good yeah that app i really
ended up releasing it's been downloaded
120 million times
and then i released another one and it's
also been downloaded like 100 million
times
and um
yeah it's really it's going really well
man how are you
i was like well uh i'm
i'm currently walking off of a cliff
because i never responded to that
initial dm
yeah everybody's like well i recently
switched from trader joe's to whole
foods i've been tickering with that
i just did my 401k match yes
fascinating um
not much you uh that's great i want to
share one other story that's kind of
related to do things that don't scale
this is something
i actually learned from those guys dylan
and henry so i'm a big fan of this like
idea that
you have to find a way to learn from
three groups of people
people that have done it
before so people who've done it a bunch
of times so that's you know people
normally try to go learn from them
mentor type of people
people that are in the game their peers
just alongside you that's kind of how we
got to know each other we were in a peer
group a mastermind group and no we
haven't made it but like we're all
trying to make it at the same time and
so we can learn a lot from each other
and then lastly is people who are just
starting out in the game fresh they
don't know any better and
there is a certain tactic to like a
spend time with each of those three
groups and then b
be humble enough and know how to ask the
right question so that you know how to
actually get advice from all three of
those groups because if you ask the same
question to all three you're not gonna
get
valid information you're not gonna get
the right answers from all three right
like the question you would ask to
somebody who's been through it before
and the things you should talk to them
about are different than the ones that
you should talk to your
your buddy who's going through it right
now and the 19 year old who just
graduated from college you can't ask the
same question so i'll tell you something
that the sort of the 19 21 year old or
whatever i don't know how old they were
at the time maybe 21 22. uh dylan and
henry they were fans of the pod
then they flew they offered to come help
us with our video setups at the time and
previously they were fans of the pod and
they would chop up clips for us and
share it on social media and a lot of
their videos were beautiful awesome and
they just brute forced their way to
having a relationship with us
exactly and that became a a full-on
agency that does you know pretty well
they they did it for us that they did it
for the all-in podcast they did it for a
bunch of and so people kind of know them
now
um but at the time nobody really knew
who they were they were just guys who
just graduated from college they had
their own podcast which was kind of like
ours uh but no you know you can go look
at the views nobody nobody watches the
thing that's okay like you know it's
most podcasts nobody listens to
especially ones by guys who just
graduated from college
but they flew out to our house there and
they were installing the like kind of
studio setup in my garage at the time
and um and i went out there i was like
you guys need some water you guys are
like you guys are right you guys you
guys eating anything i was like kind of
like parenting them i was like you know
what are you guys okay what are you
doing here and um and so i went out
there and i started shooting the [__]
with them i was talking to them and i
was like so what's your guys is like
i was like give me advice like if i was
your friend and i'm like you guys got a
podcast that's pretty cool like most
people you raised don't have a podcast
like
what do you what's your strategy what
are you trying to do why are you trying
to do it what are you trying to do
and i was like explain it to me like i
was your buddy and they're like well
um
you know we kind of we like podcasting
it's fun so that's why we do it the
second thing is um we just think that
like making content like we don't have
money to go advertise we don't have like
we don't have connections that we could
just go knock on a door and get into
some get distribution somewhere so like
content is our only chance so we just
wanted to get good at content the best
way to get good is just do it a bunch i
was like all right that's another smart
thing and i go but nobody's watching
your [__] right so like
is it even working
it's kind of like what you're saying
about this band thing like does this
even work like this is cool it's
interesting but is this valuable like is
this actually gonna work yeah and he
goes oh i'm just wait he is nobody
watches it today
he goes but someday if we start to get
people to watch
there is now a library he goes we call
it our binge bank
it's a place where you can go and you
can binge
dylan and henry
and i was like he's like yeah well
basically we just want to have a rabbit
hole for you to go go down because if
anybody ever gets it like today nobody's
interested but if people ever get
interested i want to have this bank of
content that they can go binge and sure
enough after like you know 45 minutes
down this rabbit hole you're gonna walk
out being like i think i love these guys
i feel like i know these guys and i want
to hang out or work with these guys
and i heard that i was like that's
really [__] smart i was like that's
the way to think about content
because most content doesn't just like
immediately hit and blow up
but you want to have this and i thought
about it because i was like there are
several people who i've gone down that
rabbit hole with and i've come out with
that same exact conclusion after a
45-minute dig you do this all the time
like you discover somebody you go read
everything there is about them you go
read their old blog you watch their old
talks and you come out you be like this
guy is awesome this girl is amazing
and they had to create that like library
of themselves that personal library to
go and let you binge and i thought about
it because you know the band like the
the guy macklemore the like the famous
rapper guy
i remember maybe 10 years ago now
me and my buddy trevor we started like
we like found his one of his songs and
we were like oh this guy's cool who is
this guy
and he had a binge bank he had these
vlogs he was doing on youtube of him
like
trying to make it as a rapper it'd be
like we're going to do this show at this
small college in wichita oh
we like we're wait every day right now
we're waking up at this time we're
trying to record in the studio because
we suck at
creating the creative process so we're
just trying to train ourselves right
they were just like just kind of sharing
along the way and we watched this stuff
and we were like i remember these videos
had less than a thousand views there
were like 700 views on youtube at the
time like i just went back and looked at
it now those have each like millions or
like close to a million views each on
those videos at the time less than a
thousand
and we became super fans of this guy why
because it's fun to be early we liked
what they were all about and we felt
like the quality of content was like
higher than the views and so that made
it for like an exciting it's like we
found a treasure dude people say that in
our comments on youtube
like oh i'm like i'm i'm surprised this
is bigger or like i'm happy to be here
yeah they're like they're like i'm happy
we're catching it yeah and and that that
definitely gives me encouragement it
makes me happy but yeah people say that
in our you little do they know that like
our podcast has like 10 times more
download so they're like oh this little
shitty podcast only has 10 000 videos on
this thing or 10 000 views on this thing
and i'm like yeah we suck
share
please share please
um but i i'm a big fan of this binge
bank concept i've i once i thought once
they said that that clicked with me i
started thinking about our stuff that
way and then also i started remembering
yeah there's actually a bunch of people
who i've gone down their rabbit hole and
like and actually there could be like a
product that's like this i know youtube
is kind of structured this way but i
kind of wish that you could just have a
thing which is like your greatest hits
it's like yo if you if you're kind of
interested in me
this is the curated rabbit hole so this
is my tweet that went viral this is this
video this was the first thing i ever
made this was you know this blog post i
wrote back in the day it's kind of
stupid but like you know it captured how
i was thinking at the time i have two
tools that i use regularly and i'm
paying subscribers up the first any do
you read a lot of biographies
no none so i read about take over the
world yeah i read a ton of biographies
and so any biography that talks about a
person who is a little bit pre-internet
era i'm a subscriber of newspapers.com
which has aggregated like every
newspaper ever so like for example i was
reading a biography about dan gilbert or
something about dan gilbert the founder
of rocket mortgage i think it's called
the guy who owns the cleveland cavaliers
or i forget he owns everything and so
like his company got it was called rock
financial originally his company got
popular in the 90s and so i just googled
rock financial dan gilbert set
newspapers.com to 1985 says i knew
that's when you started to 1990 uh and
then went public in 92 so i was like i'm
gonna find everything i read all these
articles uh about him before he was like
you know it was like really like he was
in the making at that point and so
that's like my favorite tools
newspapers.com the second one for
anything that's internet related is web
archive so like whenever i talk to
anyone who's like popular on the
internet i go and look back at right
when they started i like to look at
their old websites and you could like
see the trend and you can see the
trajectory and that starts that teaches
me a little bit about patterns and like
all right it's okay and it also makes me
feel like all right it's okay to be
shitty even at this size it's okay to be
only okay around this size you know what
i mean
totally totally yeah you go look at
early startup landing pages i have a
blog post about this actually like 10
throwback
uh landing pages and it's like go look
at the first version of airbnb of uber
of snapchat of all these things and then
you'll be like oh why are we trying to
perfect this before lunch like
if you could start there and end up
where these guys did like i can start
wherever the hell i am now and launch
and then
make it better over time um
do you uh you want to go to can i let me
let me bring up one so yeah this this
guy dm to me and i found his youtube
video and it was really amazing so
basically into
this has got me thinking on this whole
topic but in 2014 this guy graduated
from stanford and he got five job offers
and he did this video that he goes
here's the offers that i got in 2014 and
here's what happened and here's like how
like this story played out so he in the
video it's really great so uh actually
it looks like someone's highlighting the
video what's his name how do people find
this his name is rahul so if you google
like rahul
uh tech pond pandey
yeah so you google that or just like
rahul and then like tech jobs and i bet
you will come up so basically i'm gonna
summarize it but here the video is great
but here's basically the offers that he
got so the offers that he got from
twitter with a combination of stock and
salary was 190 000 with a combination of
stock and cash his facebook offer was
two hundred thousand dollars a year his
microsoft one was around also two
hundred thousand dollars a year his
square one around 160 000 a year and
this is both a combination of stock
equity and sign-up bonus and his google
one was 250 000 a year now fast forward
eight years what would that stock plus
cash be worth so basically the stock the
cash is mostly stagnant i think he added
like eight percent annual growth the
stock he looks at what each uh what it
grew since then so his twitter comp fast
forward it would almost be the same
because their stock hasn't grown his
facebook stock it actually would have
gone a lot higher but right now facebook
stock is down a ton and so his
facebook's uh
first year comp went from 200 to 220.
his microsoft comp
it started at 200 if you fast forward
today it would be worth around three
hundred thousand dollars a year now
here's where things get interesting his
square stuff and and he was only 22 when
he graduated or something like that and
he his first year salary and comp back
then would be 160 000
fast forward the stock is now worth a
580 000 and his google stuff was worth
250 000 a year now worth almost 700 000
a year and keep in mind so here's a few
takeaways from this the first takeaway
he said this funny thing in the video he
goes square offered me something uh that
i didn't think was any good because the
recruiter said you know if square one
day becomes a seven billion dollar
company the stock that we're offering
you now it's only worth a hundred
thousand dollars over four years it
could be worth four hundred thousand
dollars but he goes i'm really doubtful
that square will ever be a seven billion
dollar company now it's worth 50 billion
and it's down right now i think at its
peak it was 70 billion uh so the thing
that is really hard to understand is
that everything at the time most things
seem expensive and the reason why things
seem expensive is because exponential
growth is incredibly challenging to
understand so if i tell you that
something is going to grow at seven
percent a year every single year that's
actually kind of hard to understand but
that what that means is it's going to
double every 10 years if it's going to
grow if it's going to grow at 30 a year
which a lot of these tech companies are
that means it's going to double i think
every two or three years and like
exponential growth is really hard to
understand the another thing that is
really interesting is uh leveraging
offers
and negotiating is very possible even if
you're a 22 23 24 year old and so you
always do better when you have another
offer in hand and you play them uh off
one another and finally the most
important thing
for people listening
employees at tech companies
can get meaningfully rich
and people don't talk about that enough
because it's a fairly safe way if you
are good enough it's a high bar if you
are good enough to get but it's still
like a million plus jobs if you add
together fang
around there and they hire tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands a
year so it's not like that coveted but
if you can get a job at one of these
tech companies and i'm talking about a
tech company that's growing quickly and
has at least a thousand employees
relatively safe it is such a good way to
build the wealth in a low risk way and
the final most important thing on top of
that is now's the time so we're you're
talking about square being worth like
you know it might be worth seven billion
dollars i i have a very small lens here
but i see what the private company
valuations are they have reset and even
better the public companies have reset
so we have square facebook twilio maybe
robin hood i think like a company like
hubspot or something like that a coin
base all these valuations are pretty low
if you ask me and i think now's the time
where you can get some of these offers
where you're getting paid 100 200 300
000 a year in equity and that could be
worth potentially eight figures in 10
years
that's really interesting and a great um
ad for hubspot very well done very
native i enjoyed that one
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
the
when we were selling bebo
we had
a bunch of conversations and then you
know you sort of compare offers you're
like all right we had i think at the end
we ended up with three offers we had a
facebook offer
we had the twitch offer and we had a
not papered but like only because we
turned it down early but he was
interested the the discord offer
and
and i did an exercise recently where i
looked back and i said what was i
thinking then because i wrote it all
down
and how did it actually play out
and i'll be damned if i wasn't wrong on
every single thing i believed
yeah let's walk through this yeah let's
go through each one so for example we'll
start with the one that's relevant to
what you're talking about which is the
stock so so basically discord was like
look
uh we like you guys we think this is
cool but we there's no way we would come
up with cash like you're talking about
so it would need to be
just a tiny bit of cash and then mostly
stock but like we think our stock is
great so what would uh let's say let's
say that you walked away with a million
dollars of discord stock back then and
back then it wasn't that long ago that
was four years ago yeah less than four
years three years ago three four years
ago something like that so at the time i
went and talked to one of discord's
investors i was like what do you think
about this and they were like well it's
real simple like
today let's say discord is valued just
around two you know one and a half two
billion dollars
um so let's say two billion
um
i know i think at the time discord was
valued at a billion and it was one
billion then and he goes you're
basically just betting that discord
could be worth five billion if if it
gets to five
then this is the best offer and if it's
not going to get to five then this is
the worst offer and so you just have to
like you know make an educated decision
about that
and i was like in my head i was like
well i do like i was a big admirer of
discord i was like this court is kind of
amazing uh the ceo at discord jason he's
kind of amazing he of all the meetings
that we took i thought he was the
he was actually the most impressive
in there and he cut straight to the
chase and was like yeah
i'll do this
no you know the cash is going to be
small maybe one two three million
dollars um and then the rest will be
stock and so you know you guys have to
yeah is that interesting to you and at
the time i was like no because that
sounds really speculative and like
illiquid and like i can't go buy
anything cool and i can't like i the no
the total number as valued today sounds
way lower yeah and in my head i was just
like i can't do this fast forward
discord i think is worth about 15
billion now so it would have been by far
the best
deal
uh so we had a million dollars deal if
they gave you a million dollars of stock
pro and private valuations that would be
worth 15 million now in four years right
correct and we were getting more than a
million dollars of stock if we had done
that deal okay so uh so that it was it
was the worst deal it would have turned
out to be that so now there was one
caveat which is it was going to be
vested so you know i'd also have to
spend you know three years earning that
stock or four years earning that stock
which i i didn't yeah you probably would
have been fired way before that
yes
so yeah one of the odds i was going to
capture all that i don't know but like
it just shows you know uh how our brain
is not really like the idea of discord
becoming worth 15 billion was not really
like it didn't seem very likely but in
actuality the odds were probably in its
favor but it seemed like a very low
probability of things it just sounded
big it sounded like a big jump it's like
is it am i betting that discord's gonna
become 15 times bigger than it is today
and actually yeah i did like the user
base grew by two or three x the
monetization grew the the overall market
grew right there's like all these
different ways that you just multiply
these things together
and you get you arrive at this private
market valuation now and also whatever
private markets have corrected maybe
it's not worth as much now but like you
know it's hard to say it's illiquid
then the next one is the facebook offer
and it's like all right well facebook's
offer is higher in cash higher in stock
um
but we don't know about this we don't
know exactly which which stock's going
to perform better facebook or amazon
they both seem like great stocks
and so then it came down to intangible
factors and we ended up ruling out
facebook for some intangible factors we
which were in retrospect somewhat silly
reasons to decide uh the first was
like twitch was the leader in game
streaming and facebook was like nobody
watches game shooting on facebook at the
time and i was like oh man this is just
gonna be like another startup like they
they're they're called facebook but like
in this niche they're at zero and
they're hoping that we can help them win
and like
oh man and we're gonna be pushing a
boulder up a hill i was like i just want
to go join the warriors and go on the
winning team facebook just had decided
they were gonna win yet
yeah exactly and also like my mentor was
like that's such a stupid way to think
about this like you're gonna walk into
facebook and they're gonna be like um
cool game streaming's over here and
you're like actually i'm gonna wander
around this area over here i'm gonna go
play in virtual reality i'm gonna go to
ai i'm gonna go to the you know news i'm
gonna he's like you can just walk into
any other department you want just go do
that thing he's like they'll forget you
even exist after they hire you like
you're worried about what your
day-to-day life is going to be like
there and like you have no idea what
your daily life is going to be like
there and he was absolutely right by the
way have you ever been to the facebook
campus
yeah it's it's basically just like a
better college the way that i describe
it it's like a mall where everything's
free so like they have like a food court
and they don't have just one pizza place
they've got many pizza places and it's
one my wife worked there and i would go
and i'm like oh this is the best thing
ever and they have restaurants like a
sushi restaurant everything's free
they've got a ice cream place
everything's free they've got a
woodworking shop everything's free a
laundry place a barber a dentist the
barber that's that's the biggest one i
was like food i expected but when i just
saw you just walk over to this guy and
get a haircut i was like damn that was
like that was like a big draw for me i
was like i could just i don't have to go
anywhere it's just free i just walk in
and get a haircut that's kind of amazing
yeah they're like it's free all you have
to give us is your life
deal yes
did you say there's two pizza shops
so how much would the facebook so a
million in facebook back uh four years
ago would be worth what
um a million in facebook stock
would have been uh it's it's gone i
think up 30 since then so it's like you
know million would have been 1.3
right so that's the like where the stock
landed at it
was about double so at its peak it would
have been double right so and so in that
one we made the mistake of basically
um
optimizing for really intangible things
one one that seemed really tangible was
like they weren't going to take our
whole team and i was like oh i don't
want to like toast at the celebration
party of this acquisition and be like
but not you four they didn't hire you
guys so like uh
you know it's been awesome the rest of
us we're gonna go and you guys
you won't believe the recommendation
letter i'm gonna write you right like
that that would have been
[Laughter]
so that wasn't gonna feel good of course
as soon as we rejected them and they
were like why and i was like well the
team thing they're like dude we would
have just hired them a few months later
we just didn't have the head count yet
like he's like uh he's like that's why
and i was like yeah and the commute was
really far down there he's like dude we
have an sf office we could have got you
in i was like awesome
the commute they have a bus like a bus
that basically has like a restaurant
cafe like toilet internet tv on the bus
it's not even a real commute anymore
yeah people on the bus complained that
like oh my god like the the line for the
pedicure on the bus was so long this
morning it's like
i don't know what you're complaining
about anyway so we made a decision we
made it it was we made a really hard
decision and whatever ended up fine but
i guess like my point is
it's really hard to forecast and predict
these things and especially hard to
forecast and predict what stock is going
to be worth down the road that's awesome
uh wow so so i have another topic that i
want to go to
all right quick i two quick ideas
one is around what i just talked about
predictions so
um there's this company that uh brandon
sent me that's called
pressytaste
i don't even know what this is a
horrible name pressytaste if you go to
presleytaste.prcitase.com
and it's some kind of like basically
it's a prediction engine i don't even
honestly know exactly how this works but
basically what it's doing is
it's using data like um
cameras um like historical trends
whatever and what it's trying to do is
tell the person in the back
like how many burgers to put on the
stove like how many how many fries to
take out of the freezer uh because it's
basically like how can we help you
predict demand
and so this idea aside i actually think
that there's like a lot of different
ways where this is really valuable so
for example we own an e-commerce store
and we're always trying to predict like
how much inventory should we order we're
ordering you know six to nine months in
advance sometimes
and it's so hard to forecast what's the
world gonna be like six months from now
it's like oh yeah turns out there was a
pandemic a war a war
like you know stemi checks that like
caused everything to go up and then like
everything that could go down and then
shipping broke and like it was
impossible to predict
but
every bit like every better prediction
saves us a lot of money
and so i actually think that there's
like a whole bunch of business problems
that entrepreneurs could go after that
basically just help you predict how much
demand there will be there's a couple
different ways you could go about this
so for example for our e-com store it'd
be nice to know how other e-com stores
are trending are we all trending up
trending down by how much percent
year-over-year in our category because
that would kind of tell us like where
the overall market demand is uh another
prediction might be you know if i'm if
i'm a restaurant what is the foot
traffic or the sort of drive-through
traffic like this time of year right
september or in this weather pattern how
much traffic should i expect today that
might tell me what i need for staffing
and for you know food today versus any
other day and if you just think about
like if you can be smarter and cut waste
by 10 to 15 percent
in in these types of businesses and
these types of industries that's
probably going to add up to like the
tens of billions or hundreds of billions
of dollars per year of money saved and
uh so i think these businesses are very
interesting this whole like demand
prediction uh industry is very
interesting to me dude i have done a ton
of research in the trends predicting
business obviously like we have this
thing called trends and before launching
that i was like what what should we do i
think i told you about this years ago
but everything i'm about to say it's
from years ago of research and i'm doing
it mostly off memory so i'm going to be
a little bit off but not totally off but
have you heard of this company called
wgsn i think i told you about them
yeah they're the ones who like they like
say like the color of the year is
lavender and the smell of the year is
like you know
yeah lily or whatever but listen to this
so they're publicly traded so these
numbers are actually facts so the 2001
sorry 2021 revenue was 91 million
pounds
it's a british company so 91 million
pounds so i don't know what that would
be 130
yeah
yeah like i don't know the conversion of
monopoly money to real money but uh
no 91 million pounds listen to their
adjusted or their ebitda was 41 million
so basically for every dollar they made
uh 45 was like net income profit and
what they do is
they tell you which colors are going to
be popular and i'm pretty sure the
product they only have 6 500 customers
so they're paying like 25 grand a year
or something like that and i think the
product basically is a quarterly pdf
that tells you what colors they think
might be popular and i'm almost positive
the way that they get this is they put
like tablets at fashion schools and they
just ask students like what they're
feeling what they're liking things like
that so it's like they're asking fashion
people i guess the people who are like i
guess they like like are you a hipster
are you a gay guy who lives in fort
greene brooklyn like what like whatever
you the qualifications are for like you
are whatever you think is cool the
normies you know like me are gonna like
start wearing you know what i'm saying
like what about you later ten months
later yeah yeah oh do you are you an 18
year old who has 100 000 followers on
tic toc check oh okay so like whatever
they think there's going to be cool
that's what they like what they predict
is going to be cool and uh it's just a
pdf and a real life use case of this is
like starbucks is gonna like make a
hundred thousand uniforms
millennial pink is the new color so
therefore let's make sure our name tags
are this color so it's a no-brainer to
spend 25 000 to get this like quarterly
pdf as well as the ability to like dm
someone who works at wgsn and say like
which shade of green is like the thing
that we should be using and so that's an
interesting business and this trend
predicting uh space
i um i talked to somebody who does like
a fashion company or whatever
and they were like a fashion company or
whatever
yeah as you can tell i wear a blue shirt
my fashion senses you know it's frozen
in like the third grade right like i was
writing cursive the last time i thought
about fashion
the uh
and they were like lemons so in this
year and i was like what like like i
didn't i didn't understand what does
that mean i mean a lemon like i thought
they were temporary fruit and they were
i thought they were talking about like
literally like what you eat and they're
like no as like a print or a pattern or
a color
and i was like okay i was like it sounds
like you're just making things up they
just pulled up their dashboard and they
were like
no like
what look at the difference between like
lemon and pineapple and it's like lemon
juice pineapples were everywhere
recently weren't they it was it was a
bad example but it was like you know
basically like you you guys pick
is apples hot right now no apples apples
are [__] out dude apples are like you
know they're so out right now lemons are
so in pineapple what does that mean
are so in it's like a picture of a lemon
on a shirt yeah like a design with a
lemon on it or a pattern or whatever
right like all right um or or you know
same thing with like scents and color
palettes and things like that and so
and i was like there's no way i was like
this is all just like you know isn't
this just you know ad agency fluff
they're just fluffing each other with
these like you know random ass like
things and they're like no like this
stuff is like the bible to us we
we need to know what people are caring
about in order to do that i don't know
if it's this exact
wsn or whatever i don't know if that's
the exact one but they're like this
could be a concept of like knowing which
colors which sense which which styles
which uh like uh dude is that our
that's so exhausting
yeah it sounds like a horrible business
to be in like if i'm going to be in the
fashion business i'm going to be in the
men's tuxedo business that [__] has not
changed for literally a hundred years
have you seen jack and titanic
that's the same [__]
i'm going straight big and tall for men
because literally the only criteria is
like do you fit
right
you fit
if you fit you're in if you don't fit
you're out that's your only i was like
that's what i like i like a simple yes
or no when it comes to fashion it's just
do you fit or not because i just can't
find stuff that fits
dude fashion's exhausting i i i that's
not a business i want to be in although
i do think like there are some brands
you know what brand freaking crushes it
and i never buy any other stuff though
because it's just too expensive but a
louis vuitton louis vuitton uh they're
like suitcases louis pecan yeah
lp
um
[Laughter]
dude they've crushed it for like 150 200
years and it's the same ass logo the
same colors and it's just timeless i do
love those timeless things they they do
there's like a little arbitrage going
around i don't know if you've seen this
but like
with your few months ago somebody said
this they're like because the dollar the
euro like got to parity
and
the luxury stores hadn't changed the
prices so basically like um things were
always typically priced higher in
dollars than in euros uh or whatever you
might get that backwards but like
you the louis vuitton bag you if you
were in paris you could buy it in euros
for a certain price
that same bag was selling for more that
same day if you just sold it in us
dollars to a us customer and in paris
you would also get the vat refund so
you'd get you basically net getting
something like 30 to 35 percent
under market and that was like your
spread that you could then go and sell
it for in the united states it was like
kind of crazy and so
um there's like whole businesses that
are around these like the version of a
drug mule so it's like you can just pay
someone who's traveling
to like stuff a louis vuitton bag in
their in their suitcase and bring it
over for you across the border
and um
just because like you know going
flying to europe to do this yourself is
kind of inconvenient but there's already
people flying from europe to the us
every day and so there's whole
businesses that are based around this
like travel arbitrage and flying
i just did research on one of these that
i discovered it's called grabber so the
url is
g r a b r
dot io so they went with like the
misspelling and the dot io so you know
they're really a startup but it's uh
grabber.io and their whole [__] is shop
anywhere travel everywhere i guess
that's a really bad tagline but
basically what it means is it connects
you with people who are with these drug
mules these louis vuitton mules it
connects you with people who are going
to
overseas places and you they'll buy [__]
for you and you'll give them the money
and it's like a marketplace for that
this i've got the stupid example of that
there's this thing called a wicked laser
because i'm like a grown up i'm like
is the wicked part just like yourself
describing a standard laser or is it
actually called that
how much of all of your world with money
basically there's these
i found this laser online
this laser pointer online that's so
strong that they made it illegal in
america
and if you shine something like a piece
of paper it catches it catches fire
and you can't have it because it reaches
jets in the air and it's a chinese
company and obviously i saw this laser
and it's a 300 laser but you could only
ship it to someone in canada and i'm
like i want
a laser that can light [__] on fire like
why do you not want that that will go
perfect in my collection of like tasers
this one laser i have a bb gun a blazer
yeah a blazer from menswear
so
i had to find someone who would buy this
in china for me and get it from canada
to america for my 300 laser
you should go work at grabber dot io
that's what you should go do
yeah
we're just gonna sponsor every in cell
like uh subreddit like
do you like lasers you're tired of not
getting your laser
tired of driving to canada for your
favorite lasers
use grabber
grab it for you bring it to you
you're a 12 year old with money
i saw this tick tock speaking of cool
lasers i saw this tick tock
a laser pointer that somebody was in
their bed and they're pointing it at
their light switch they go watch this
they just held it on the as they go and
it applied just enough pressure
to turn it off and i'm like this is not
real i think i don't know how this is
edited
but
i was like the comments were like
bro it's not real but like
is
[Laughter]
because imagine not having to get out of
your bed to turn your light off at night
just grabbing your laser pointer off the
bed stand and turning your light off
that's dude so just imagine getting an
instagram where you see a guy go watch
this and he shines something across the
room and it lights it on fire that's
what i got caught with these wicked
lasers
wait how'd the light switch go down
i don't know man i never got to the
bottom of it
i liked and followed to find out for
part two
they got me
they said if i didn't forward that that
tic tac to 10 people my family would die
of lasers i had to do it
oh my goodness that's stupid i want to
tell you about another thing that's kind
of interesting so you know like i think
you met up with this guy i think his
name he's like strip mall guy on twitter
yeah yeah i know i know he's really like
the same guy i'm one of those few people
yeah no well sure strip ball guy is his
fake name supposed to be trent
uh no there's another guy who's real
straight maybe they're two different
guys all right i think stripper real
estate trent and trip and strip mall guy
yeah i met up with the strip ball guy
and we became friends and so i have to
make sure i don't accidentally say his
name
so one of those guys i forgot which one
now sorry uh tweeted about private
security and it caught my eye because he
goes
uh man private security is booming right
now i know so many car like i've seen so
many cops who retired
and um
are just doing this because it's better
money and i was like what like okay tell
me more and so um and so i started
looking into this and basically a very
very very briefly but
do you know much about this like private
security uh like
you know like trend or industry i know
that we used to hire them for our events
because the insurance made you have one
and you and i had a buddy who we knew
who's or a friend of a friend who
started a security business he started
like an uber for bodyguards right like
did it work he tried no he that one
failed but he tried to make it like sexy
it's like he just needed to do it not
sexy
so basically okay so there's some big
players in this thing so private
security so there's companies like
securitas or if you just go to aus.com
it's allied universal security which i
think both of those are multi-billion
dollar companies yeah so one's eleven
billion that then seven billion i think
they do everything from like mall cops
to airports to events to whatever else
but like it goes like smaller and
smaller and more niche like down down as
you go like corporate security so for
example i remember when i was at at um
working at a company i saw on the ceo's
calendar
a a meeting that was like with like the
private security detail to go over like
the latest updates to the private
security i was like you got private
security it's like well yeah like you
know it's
we're rich worth a lot like you know
like worth a lot to this company so the
company literally pays for private
security for the executives um to be
able to to you know to go out and do
their thing and be safe and so i found
this kind of interesting and it makes it
like it makes sense to me and uh it
makes sense to me that there's like a
private world out there for kind of like
retired either army
military or police
that might be
higher paying and potentially you know
an easier job um than what they're doing
today
who who were the executives that had
security
uh i don't want to say but
but which company did you say the
company i didn't hear you
no because that would be okay to figure
out at that point
yeah i uh
you know like
zuckerberg and bezos they release what
their security budget is each year and i
think bezos was six million which is to
me not a lot of money
um
right for facebook they said last year
26 million was spent on zuckerberg and
his family which was six percent higher
than in 2020. so that's kind of crazy
right 26 million just on his personal
uh security you know how many people
work uh work for the secret service
no
6 000
you know how many people they protect
yeah you know how many people they
protect
25 25 people
spoken like a man who owns a taser and a
laser
dude
i met a secret service agent at a
wedding this weekend and i just asked
them everything i go tell me everything
and i you know they couldn't tell me
anything really yeah i was gonna say a
pretty shitty secret service guy and
he's like big fan of the pod happy to
share
they just read out the wikipedia to me
but like
uh it was pretty interesting um
that's cool no i don't know anything
about security but i think it's
speaking of tick tock there was a tick
tock of a guy who saw jeff bezos on the
corner in seattle just like waiting to
cross the street and he's just like hey
jeff and he like had his tick tock
recording or whatever and he's like you
know how's it going today whatever he's
like
going fantastic and he's like you know
he's ready to like walk across the
street
and they go and somebody in the comments
was like the top comment was like check
out the hand of the security guy
and you look and he had basically a
false i think it was like a false hand
and his and basically his real hand is
like in his pocket like probably holding
a gun or a taser of some some kind of
weapon and he just had like a kind of a
fake hand out
and i saw that i was like that's awesome
that's that's awesome dude you know
what's even weirder is there was a i'm a
ufc super fan there was a fight
backstage amongst the ufc fighters and
security got involved and i kept
wondering
who the [__] is doing ufc
security to keep the ufc fighters from
not fighting each other yeah you know
what i mean like what what like what
type of job are they getting here too
you know what i mean like they just see
like something happening and like what
are you going to do well you saw the the
woman that dana white hired the best buy
lady did you see this yeah she was a
football player she like kept the woman
or someone was trying to rob the best
buy and she like got down low in like an
o-line like it was like pushing her out
of the way yeah the robber was trying to
run out the store and the security guard
from best buy just starts
blocking this person from getting this
guy from getting out and he's like he's
desperately trying to get out because he
can't just be like stealing and just get
caught inside the store
and she just ends up tackling him into
like a bunch of boxes she gets fired
from best buy because best buy's like
hey uh
liability you attacked a you attacked
somebody in our store and she's like oh
my god i'm doing my job i'm a security
guard at best buy what did you want me
to do
and dana white was like that's [__]
like he went on instagram was like who
is this woman i want to hire her and
she's like now he's like personal
security guard or something like that
like she works for that really yeah
dude i always see those guys and i'm
like who
like you need like an israeli trained
like secret service agent to like i mean
who are you gonna have to protect a ufc
fighter from hitting another
jerry springer uh security guards you
have years of experience breaking this
up
this episode is really good off a
tangent but do you remember how remember
steve the security guard from jerry
speaker
probably like the top earner on cameo
right now yeah
it's actually kevin from the office or
gilbert godfrey
um
oh shoot i think gilbert just died
actually r.i.p but whatever uh
i guess
did you know that dmx died
yeah dude
yeah i saw that
you tweeted out why didn't you tell me
you knew this information you withheld
it
that reminds me of what david you know i
don't leave my house
chappelle was talking about like
celebrities and now it's weird they talk
to them during tragedies and he's like
just imagine like 9 11 and and
ja rule was like being interviewed
actually and like
you know we we need jaw right now to
make sense of this tragedy where's his
job
someone go give me a job we need john to
make sense of the strategy this tragedy
that's what that's like you wondering
like why didn't anyone fill me in that
the dmx had passed uh but yeah
he's by the way did you see this uh this
blog post is we'll close on this little
last random thing but um
check out this blog post so this guy
listened to the episode that we did with
rob dyrdek which is probably
i don't know if not the most popular
episode we did one of the most popular
episodes we've done uh people love that
one and one of the things that rob the
one of the reasons people love it is
because turns out
the kind of fun-loving skater guy from
mtv like turns out he's like an absolute
nut when it comes to personal
productivity and like personal
efficiency
you know his quote on there was i am
human optimization
and one of the things he had said was
that he writes his wife a handwritten
note every day and so this guy wrote
this blog post it was like the top post
on hacker news over the weekend
and it's called write a note to your
spouse every day and noted a note a day
keeps the divorce attorney away
and he goes um you know i was listening
to my first million
and uh rob dierdick was on there he says
that uh he writes a note to his wife
every day because sometimes
otherwise she would be the last person
to hear from him at the end of the day
about what he was working on how he was
feeling he was usually tired by then and
wasn't really giving it you know his a
plus so he goes for the last six months
i wrote an a note to my wife every
single day he goes all right that's a
lie you know i did it most days but like
whatever here's how it went
and he goes it's amazing like we're on
the same page about like what's going on
in our lives our kids our finances how
we're spending our time we talk more
than ever now
um you know we have more trust we feel
less stressed we're less aggravated with
each other and like we're better parents
because we're kind of like more in
communication with ourselves um
about parenting
and he goes you know here's why writing
is thinking so just writing helped me
clear my mind it wasn't just me dumping
my thoughts onto her it was me like
getting my own mind clear and he gives
this outline he goes here's what i write
first i write gratitude like something
about her you know for her for how hard
she works for her looks whatever
then what i'm working on today uh and
like my goals or my deadlines anything
i'm excited about anything that's
bothering me
uh any ideas i have just like random
ideas on my head about parenting or
fixing stuff around the house
um transactional stuff like oh we need
to remember to do this we have to do
this don't forget that
um questions like hey are we going to
that thing or hey did we ever book that
you know hey do we have an event coming
up
uh and lastly again gratitude for the
life we have the the things we have the
time we have the kids we have etcetera
because i don't do all these sections
every day but those are the general
categories of things i try to write uh
it takes me just about 30 minutes if i'm
not distracted and uh you know
turn yeah it's been a huge like win for
me is it like a physical note or an
email
i think it's a physical note uh not 100
sure i guess i should start doing this
that sounds pretty cool right and then
he did this youtube video with his wife
like where they both like talked about
afterwards because the post blew up on
hacker news it got like probably you
know 100 000 views or something like
that so then they like did an interview
together like talking about this little
habit it's pretty cool right yeah this
is awesome uh i just dm'd him while
you're talking saying this is uh amazing
and this is a really good headline write
a note write a note to your spouse every
day a note a day keeps a divorce
attorney away this is a really good
title this is a beautiful find um
i think i guess i'll start doing this
right this is pretty sick
it sounds smart maybe i'll start by
talking to her then
no that seems like a no-brainer i'm like
reading this and i'm like huh
all upside pretty much no downside why
am i not doing this
right
good for me
how can i wheeze a lot of doing this
sorry my brain's not coming for any
valid reason not to do this
no like the calculations are like going
in my head i'm like huh
yeah
you seem like a good husband do you you
probably already do this you probably
leave a sticky note on our pillow every
morning no not at all as i was reading
it same thing i was like why would i not
do this it seems really obvious but
apparently no one does it
my first example
husbands one episode at a time
i feel like we had to we had to leave
him with something useful because we
definitely got off on like you know a
tangent's tangent during this episode
dude it worked for rob i mean rob is
like successful have you seen his wife i
mean she's very beautiful i'm pretty
sure she was like a playmate uh like a
like a like a i don't know what the word
is playboy model or something i mean
she's like
uh
pretty amazing
i'm definitely doing this now
yeah
[Laughter]
here's one of the ways that i knew that
rob was like crazy rich if you google
rob dierdick home there's like 13
different articles and it's like all
about like a different like 10 million
dollar house did you mean homes did you
mean mansions
yeah and he buys all these houses and uh
he seems happy he's got his act together
so yeah i'm on board i guess
i guess i'll do this
fine
[Laughter]
all right
[Music]
you